firm under penalty of perjury the most
watched civil rights trial in america
opened with a stark accusation of murder
mr derrick chavin betrayed this badge
when he used excessive and unreasonable
force
upon the body of mr george floyd
that he put his knees upon his neck and
his back
grinding and crushing him until
the very breath no ladies and gentlemen
until the very life
were squeezed out of him as opening
arguments began in the trial of the
police encounter that sparked a racial
revolution in the streets
the lawyer for the white former
minneapolis police officer
accused of murdering a black man named
george floyd
shot back and you will learn that derek
shovin did exactly
what he had been trained to do over the
course of his 19-year career
the use of force is not attractive
but it is a necessary component of
policing
the prosecution's first witness a police
dispatcher who watched on police cameras
as officers knelt on the back
and neck of george floyd then she did
something she'd never done before
she called the police on the police
alerting a sergeant to what seemed to
her like an unusual use of force
floyd was on the ground so long she said
she thought the video had frozen
i don't know if they had used force or
not they got something out of the back
of the squad
and all of them sat on this man the
central question in this case is this
did chauvin kill floyd using
unreasonable force as the prosecution
suggests
or did a combination of drugs covet 19
and heart trouble kill him as the
defense contends
those arguments are the beginning of
what's likely to be a month-long
trial filled with painful and
potentially inflammatory testimony
with jurors watching new evidence and
re-watching that disturbing nine minutes
of video of george floyd using his final
breaths to cry out for his life
minneapolis is boarding up and bracing
for the final verdict
and the possibility it could revive the
riots of the long and violent summer of
outside the heavily fortified courthouse
floyd's family made it clear
it is american racial justice that is on
trial
they say trust the system they want us
to trust this system
well this is your chance to show us
that we can trust you judge peter cahill
says it's a police officer that's on
trial
not race but once the jury has its say
in the racially charged case of a black
man who died under the knee of a white
police officer
the crowds in the streets of minneapolis
and cities across the u.s
will render their own verdict on racial
justice in america
john hendren al jazeera minneapolis